no facemask for the president while
visiting an aerospace company repurposed
to produce masks this in defiance of his
administration's guidelines that masks
should be worn in public at all times
the president confirmed reports that he
was considering shutting down the
coronavirus task force that has been
responsible for the federal response to
the pandemic as far as the task force
mike pence and the task force have done
a great job but we're now looking at a
little bit of a different form and that
former safety and opening and will will
have a different group probably set up
for them are you saying mission
accomplished
no no no the mission accomplishes when
it's over while the president was on his
travels this document was handed over to
the office of the Special Counsel an 89
page whistleblower report alleging the
Trump administration ignored early
warnings about the corona virus the
authors dr. Rick bright the former
director of the biomedical Advanced
Research and Development Authority the
country's controlling body for vaccine
production he alleges he was unfairly
removed from his job following
complaints about the administration's
lack of urgency in reacting to the
pandemic he also specifically mentions
resisting pressure from senior officials
to fast-track the use of the drug
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
itself in treatment for the virus the
drug was heavily and repeatedly touted
by the President himself and Task Force
briefings I think it's gonna be very
exciting I think it could be a
game-changer and maybe not and maybe not
but I think it could be based on what I
see it could be a game-changer
dr. bright contends his opposition to
this position led directly to his
effective demotion as officials sought
to placate the president a lot of what
dr. bright a whistleblower complaint is
about or demonstrate is the extent to
which the government at the higher
levels is committed not to solving the
problem but to keeping Donald Trump
happy today keeping him happy tomorrow
and that's not a way to address a very
major problem like this it was only a
week ago that the FDA for
he cautioned against the use of these
drugs for the treatment of coronavirus
despite the warnings that dr. bright
made back in January perhaps the most
damning allegation in the report is that
the administration ignored or pushed
back against dr. brights emails warning
of the severity of the virus and
insisting that the national stockpile of
masks and ventilators needed to be
augmented and like other government
officials who've been demoted or fired
dr. bright is demanding his job back and
Congress will now get involved
dr. brights lawyers confirmed he's been
invited to give evidence to a House
Committee on Thursday next week Mike
Hanna al Jazeera Washington